wherever green party data expert Malta
Schmitz goes he leaves digital
footprints his cell phone's GPS reveals
his location a webcam shows him at our
camera team in the internet and the
American national security agency
records this so-called metadata without
a court order or specific reason a
scandal says Schmidt this is nappin
let's NC stuff on this is a picture of
our behavior in the internet where we
serve for we buy things who we write
emails with or chat with I wonder one
reflection is possible I thought this
might happen in individual cases where
someone is under a specific suspicion
but it turns out that everyone is being
launched that finden together with news
portal site online Schmidt's evaluated
the metadata from his smartphone it
produced a detailed surveillance report
anyone who has access to the metadata
from Malta schmitz's cell phone may as
well have planted a bug on him that can
locate him anywhere and that's just what
the NSA surveillance program is doing at
his meeting with Chancellor Angela
Merkel President Obama defended it as a
way to fight terrorism this is not a
situation where we simply go into the
internet and start searching any way
that we want this is a circumscribed
narrow system directed at us being able
to protect our people come back stronger
if we take advantage but miracles own
experts sees things differently no one's
always our understanding of the law is
that there's no reason at all to store
such information even if it's only for a
limited time if the information is not
needed to protect against dangers or to
investigate crimes von strife taught
nuba hope nishma duty to it
communications expert yan Schmidt also
thinks that unlimited storage of
information is questionable he says data
protection must have priority especially
because users of social networks like
Facebook reveal a lot about themselves
and German law protects this info
mation you say about idle a burger
Hobbit asleep I have the right to
control who can access my data from you
pathetic I give Facebook that right in
my user agreement but not the government
or secret intelligence agencies aliens
alone access to a person's metadata in
the internet provides a wealth of
information about him and the
intelligence agencies interest goes
beyond what someone has actually done
they use programs to analyze the data
and try to predict how he'll act in the
future if you know that a person is
friends with five other people and these
five voice discontent with the political
regime you can conclude on the basis of
statistical probability that the sixth
person is disaffected to even if he
doesn't say anything that even jokes
made in the internet can suddenly have
serious consequences just before setting
off for a vacation in the United States
Irishman Levin Brian tweeted before I go
and destroy America he says he meant he
planned to party but the Department of
Homeland Security refused to honor his
visa and detained him but private
individuals aren't all the NSA as mining
data on German companies to are
objecting to the surveillance
give isn't that really nice we don't
know how much the Americans have
expanded their surveillance program and
so there's a danger that German
companies are affected were a bit
worried they're conducting economic
espionage in la Gaddafi us here cluster
so that just beyond algebra to even be
it Chancellor Merkel has to respond to
the fears of people and companies in
Germany surveillance by us secret
intelligence services is a burden on
German American relations let's get
inside in the Internet age there are
always two concerns protection of
corporate intellectual property and
protection of people's privacy and of
course there's also protection from
terrorist threats that's why the balance
between freedom and security is
important the German government wants a
group of German experts to negotiate
directly with the Americans green
politician Malta Schmitz thinks that's
not enough that's if I need to stop the
United States must not clearly declare
how extensive their espionage is put the
facts on the table all the documents
that haven't been made public yet and
simply state clearly that they're ending
this practice I need to talk to praxis
Einstein nevertheless Schmitz still
doesn't want to do without the internet
but now he encrypts all his data that
way any potential surveillance will be
more difficult
you